il s'est passé une semaine depuis le
déclenchement de la campagne
les chefs se retrouve à montréal pour le
premier grand rendez vous de la campagne
bonsoir mesdames et messieurs bon
dimanche soir ce n'est pas un débat ils
font face à un barrage de questions de
trois chefs d'antenne afin de comprendre
ce qu'ils proposent aux justes aux
électeurs monsieur leroux bonsoir
bonsoir et vous trouvez le 1er interview
et françois legault au terme d'une
semaine marquée par les menaces contre
des candidats parce qu'il ya un lien à
faire avec les mesures santa peut-être
en partie le chef de la coalition avenir
québec promet des baisses d'impôts de
près de 8 milliards de dollars le québec
selon lui a les moyens de se les payer
je pense qu'il faut donner un peu d'air
aux contribuables et je pense qu'on est
capable de le faire en même temps qu'on
finance bien la santé l'éducation
nos services de base en matière
d'environnement il défend son bilan et
son projet de troisième lien entre
québec et lévis il affirme avoir des
études qui prouvent sa nécessité qu'il
n'est pas prêt à dévoiler encore et dont
il n'a pas besoin je vous pourquoi des
gens à montréal aurait plus de ponts que
les gens à québec est ce que subissent
les ja montréal arrête de regarder de
haut les jeunes québec puis de lévis la
chef libéral dominique anglade dont
certaines des promesses sont similaires
à celles de françois legault baisses
d'impôts allocations aux aînés assure
qu'elle offre une alternative à la cac
qui veut par exemple fixé le seuil
d'immigration à 50000 annuellement 60 70
min pour la première année et ensuite
j'en suis tu es ensuite la charte des
régions qui sera adopté la première
année qui nous permettrait d'avoir ses
relations avec chacune des régions du
québec elle a manifesté avec la
communauté anglophone contre la réforme
de la loi 101 elle dit s'inquiéter du
recul du français au québec mais être
contre le projet de loi 96 je ne conçois
pas qu'on dise à nos jeunes adultes qui
devront choisir un cégep en français
vers ce seul cégep en anglais ils ont le
droit de faire cette prendre cette
décision là eux-mêmes c'est un exemple
deuxième exemple vous accueillez des
gens et puis vous êtes à bout de six
mois s'est terminée vous devez avoir
appris le français s'est même pas
réaliste bonsoir monsieur nadeau dubois
bonsoir le porte parole de québec
solidaire maintenant à présenter son
plan climat aujourd'hui qui prévoit une
réduction de 55 % des émissions de gaz à
effet de serre d'ici 2030 comment on
peut faire autant en si peu de temps
c'est un défi mais on n'a pas le choix
un plan ambitieux est aussi très coûteux
notre plat ça représente des
investissements le au total de 29
milliards de dollars en infrastructures
donc en immobilisations dans un premier
mandat on est rendu là au québec il faut
investir ce qu'on propose aux québécois
québécoise c'est le plus grand chantier
depuis la révolution tranquille et
s'attaque à son tour au gouvernement
legault gabriel nadeau-dubois veut
rehausser les seuils d'immigration
également et revoir la loi sur la
laïcité de l'état mais empêcher à des
femmes d'aller enseigner dans vos écoles
parce qu'ils portent un signe religieux
je pense que c'est une mauvaise idée il
nous manque tellement prof pourquoi on
se priverait de femmes qui veulent
contribuer à nos systèmes d'éducation
passé pierre plamondon bonjour bonsoir
le chef du parti québécois sans surprise
fait de la protection du français en fer
de lance de sa campagne nous sommes le
seul parti politique à dire que la loi
96 elle est insuffisante et tous les
experts confirment notre position et
nous sommes le seul parti à vouloir
renverser ce déclin paul st pierre
plamondon veut un référendum dans un
premier mandat il prétend que ces
candidats contrairement à ceux d'autres
formations sont tous authentiques vous
êtes en vente est on va peut-être même
au rayon vaut mourir debout
non je dis on est debout et finalement
le chef du parti conservateur éric
duhaime défend son désir de faire entrer
la grogne au parlement ce qui serait
malsain ce serait que ces voix là soit à
l'extérieur est manifeste et qu'elle ne
se retrouve pas autour de la table parce
qu'il y avait un unanimisme un peu
assourdissant l'assemblée nationale
pendant plusieurs mois et ces gens là ne
se faisait pas entendre nous ne bute
s'est justement que la démocratie soit
un peu plus représentatif il aurait lui
aussi imposé des mesures sanitaires
durant la pandémie mais aurait dit il
respecter le libre choix d'installation
ça a été suivi j'attends encore la
première étude pour savoir que c'est
quoi leur impact du couvre-feu c'est
quoi et où les scientifiques là dessus
les chefs reprennent maintenant la route
prochain rendez-vous les débats
l'occasion pour le public québécois de
les voir croiser le fer ici sébastien
desrosiers radio-canada monde
et on va bien sûr ces entrevues auquel
se sont prêtés ce soir laisse un chef de
parti avec nos analystes sébastien bovet
geneviève palier et michel serrault g
bonsoir à tous les trois ans au taux de
bon sens donc c'était l'occasion pour
les chefs d'expliquer leurs programmes
de se démarquer de leurs adversaires et
de défendre son bilan dans le cas de
françois legault at il réussi tout
d'abord sébastien j'ai eu l'impression
monsieur legault a été placée parfois
sur la défensive quand il parlait du
troisième bien par exemple en disant que
c'est nécessaire de faire le troisième
bien mais tout en ajoutant qu'il ya des
études qui vont être mises à jour alors
à quoi servent les études à ce moment là
si monsieur legault ne les attend pas
avant de prendre position pour le
troisième il est donc françois legault
était placé cette fois ci dans une
situation différente de celle de 2018 il
fallait qu'il défende son bilan sur les
médecins lorsqu'il s'est fait aux
urgences notamment de son gouvernement
n'a pas livré les promesses de 2018
notamment le temps d'attendre dans les
urgences seront un médecin par québécois
donc un peu plus placé sur la défensive
j'avais l'impression ce soit pour
monsieur leubou geneviève oui mais en
même temps c'est c'est la position du
gouvernement sortant puis il ya souvent
des barrages de questions sur justement
son bilan et j'ai trouvé que monsieur
legault quand même avait plusieurs
bonnes réponses à fournir peut-être pas
les réponses que tout le monde attendait
mais
avait une parade si vous voulez leur
avait une stratégie vis-à-vis ses
réponses là le troisième mais je pense
que ça va donner demeurez thème dominant
de la campagne ça va peut-être pas la
risée par contre parce que certains ont
peut-être pas aimé sa réponse mais je
pense que d'autres notamment à québec
ont aimé quand même sa réponse est donc
on va voir la suite des choses mais je
voudrais que dans l'ensemble pour
monsieur legault j'ai l'impression que
y'a aucune de ces déclarations qui va
faire fuir des gens qui ont voté pour
lui je pense qu'il ya d'autres personnes
qui vont demeurer intéressés opposition
cas qui ont pas voté pour la cup en 2018
mais qui seraient intéressés à le faire
cette fois ci et pas de questions à se
poser sur la place du privé en santé
ce qui est quand même important
peut-être jamais michel oui oui
effectivement je pense que cela il vient
d'échapper on a posé la question
monsieur dray mais pas monsieur on
aurait pu d'ailleurs pointé davantage le
thème de la santé en même temps il ya
gérer une pandémie donc il ya quand même
des choses qui sont dites à propos de la
pandémie puis les gens connaissent son
bilan aussi mais bon la santé va
demeurer thèmes récurrents de la
campagne michel
c'est sûr qu'on va venir sur la santé
parce que aujourd'hui cet effort dans le
cadre de l'émission mais je suis le mot
est dit ah non ça va bien marcher début
et mi octobre dirigé par le privé parce
que le système privé fonctionne mieux je
nage dans la base mais c'est pas une
c'est pas une réponse très forte et
n'éclaire le vue je le vaux quand il est
sur la défensive et c'est inévitable ces
produits ne sortant
parfois devient un peu irritable bon là
il n'était pas dans une situation de
débat mais à deux débats qui s'en
viennent et il est clair que les partis
d'opposition aux prix des voyages les
endroits où son argumentaire est moins
par le troisième c'est évident mais
aussi sur lesquels il devient un petit
peu il reçu dans un débat ça peut être
compliqué ça allons maintenant de la
chef libéral dominique anglade dont la
campagne connaît un début difficile son
équipe est toujours à court de candide
en fait de huit candidats je pense
qu'elle en a parlé ce soir mais est ce
qu'elle a pu redonner un élan à sa
campagne sébastien
et la patrie bûcher elle a même montré
et démontré de l'émotion à la toute fin
quand elle disait qu'elle ne regrettait
pas d'avoir quitté la caq parce qu'elle
veut qu'avant un parti plus incluses et
vous des politiques plus inclusive
mais la porte frapper de coups de
circuit et c'est pas été un feu
d'artifice à tout le moins elle à
mobiliser sa base elle a été très clair
sur la question de la loi 21 d'avoir 96
qu'elle ne reconduirait pas la cause
d'un app store pour protéger celle wade
des jugements des tribunaux et qu'elle
laissera aux tribunaux le soin de juger
si ces lois sont constitutionnels donc
c'est ça mobilise sa base très
certainement est ce qu'elle a réussi ce
soir et élargir sa base électorale
je suis pas convaincu mais à tout le
monde je dirais qu elle a pas réussi à
relancer nécessairement sa campagne
électorale mais a donné un aperçu quand
même
dubois duquel elle peut se chauffer
d'une certaine et elle s'est imposée
comme la chef du parti d'économies
geneviève alors d'entraidé c'est comme
ça que c'est à une qualifiée oui à mon
avis c'est là qu'elle a raté l'occasion
parce qu'on lui a posé clairement la
question c'est quoi les paroles parti
d'économies qu'entend du parti libéral
et la réponse avait été satisfaisante
alors va nous amener sur une de ses
propositions qui est oui d'immigration
qu'il faut en faire plus pour un manque
de main d'oeuvre mais l'économie c'est
plus que ça le parti libéral a une
tradition historique économique
important alors quoi ta blessure ça
alors je me serais attendu à des bons
création de richesses voici comment on
va faire l'entreprise privée l'équilibré
budgétaire toutes ces questions là et
les vraiment passé à côté donc on va
encore se demander j'ai bien
l'impression c'est quoi le parti
d'économies mais on nous ramène à
l'inflation de logements l'immigration
qui sont importants actuellement mais
dans deux ans dans trois ans est-ce que
ça va être encore importante c'est quoi
la vision plus globale son lot puis oui
michel votre réaction
je pense que maintenant à glab une
position particulière chf de position
c'est elle la première grande attente et
aucun n'est pas des chefs des partis
d'opposition dans notre budget brut
gaffe ce soir rien ça mais elle n'était
pas notoirement meilleur que les autres
et c'est ça je pense qui fait que
c'est un exercice qui lui rapporterait
pas beaucoup parce que à la fin on
certains chefs d'opposition qu'ils y
envoient premier ministre si ce que je
ferais voici comment je me comporterai
on n'avait pas l'impression d'avoir des
futurs premiers louise devant nous avec
ma la marinade aujourd'hui bon c'est le
céderaient qu'elle a eu une semaine
extrêmement difficiles et quand elle
pouvait tourner le coin
elle a eu une soirée très correct mais
est-ce que c'est suffisant pour dire ah
tiens je donne une deuxième chance à 2
min k réglable surtout quand on pense
que les appuyer dans l'album francophone
soit aussi bonne chose ouais
gabriel nadeau-dubois maintenant de
québec solidaire il a présenté
aujourd'hui son plan climat donc
beaucoup de milliards en juin 9
milliards notamment pour le transport
collectif mais ce qui vous a fait réagir
je pense tous les trois c'est son projet
de consulter de constitution pour un
québec indépendant et qui serait soumis
à un référendum on a parlé de référendum
dans son cas sébastien oui ben en fait
ça fait partie du programme de québec
solidaire depuis plusieurs années l'idée
de les gens s'y perdre parce que on se
pose des questions sur la démarche
référendaire ou la démarche
souverainiste au québec solidaire mais
l'idée c'est de former une assemblée
constituante donc des citoyens qui
élaboraient une constitution du québec
dans laquelle on est fiers vrai des
choses et qui elle serait soumise à un
référendum donc c'est ça la démarche
n'est pas question d'un référendum sur
la souveraineté pendant un premier
mandat d'un éventuel gouvernement du
québec solidaire mais disons que on se
pose souvent des questions sur la
volonté souverainiste du québec
solidaire ce soit monsieur nadeau dubois
eu l'occasion de préciser que du
référendum mais sur une constitution du
québec pas sur la souveraineté ça
viendrait peut-être après mais la
constitution sera soumise à référendum
et québec solidaire qui doit se
démarquer justement des autres partis
dont le parti québécois dans son projet
geneviève blanc mais il a fait un peu le
contraire parce que premièrement avec sa
plateforme ces propositions
environnementales ou toute la journée on
a dit oui mais la proposition ressemble
beaucoup à celle du parti québécois puis
effectivement c'est pas mal similaire
monsieur nadeau dubois n'étaient pas
obligés de mentionner le mot référendum
aujourd'hui ce soir c'est lui-même qui
l'a amené il y avait pas de question
piège à cet égard là il va tomber dans
le piège alors si lui même se sentir
besoin de mentionner ce mot là je pense
bien que c'est de faire un clin d'oeil
au pq qui te dire ben oui on a un regard
aussi sur vous puis si vous venez jouer
dans nos plates-bandes on va les jouer
un avocat dans donc je m'attends à
partir de maintenant une ne tente là le
québec solidaire et la cac mais je
m'attends aussi à québec solidaire et le
parti québécois et ça viendra québec
solidaire fiction c'est intéressant
comme dynamique avoir sa voix michel
je pense qu'il faut chaud que beaucoup
de gens pensent qu'au national du bobl
police à l'issue de cette consultation
donc le référendum s'est pas extrêmes
pertinent et pas extrêmement imminent
non plus cela dit je pense que
objectivement le mieux que québec cette
guerre pourrait espérer c'est d'avoir le
quotidien officiel et sur ce plan-là je
pense qu'il a eu une bonne soirée dans
le sens où il exposait ses politiques de
façon très claire il a le sens de la clé
pensée et d'autre part ils
pouvaient dédramatiser un certain nombre
de choses toute cette idée du radical
hans énumère étudiants je pense qu'il y
avait plus l'air d'un politicien qui
s'est connaissez bien c'est aussi que de
quelqu'un quand comment le soulor
d'écrire deux très fiables alors parlons
maintenant de passer pierre plamondon at
il réussi à se faire connaître davantage
ce soir je vais recommencer par michel
faire salon
bien sûr que c'est de la visibilité pour
rejoindre le club au dos et il est
apparu très sympathique ou si c'est ce
qui c'est important dans le contexte
parce que les gens le connaissent pas
auquel on a donné on peut avoir tout
sauf d'image de quelqu'un qu'on conquis
ceux qui sont pas exacts cela dit a
passé énormément de temps sur la
question
du référendum de
il a aussi parlé beaucoup de la langue
mais il n'y a pas parlé beaucoup du
reste de son programme
on sait que monsieur saint pierre de
l'abandon du parti québécois on va le
défendre de francs si on n'avait pas
besoin d'eux qu'ils disaient nos poils
alors peut-être comme peut-être un peu
marre que cette chance à bernard tapie
pour les gens qu'ils connaissent pas ça
a été une journée de genève
oui d'accord avec cette analyse là et
j'ajouterais peut-être que l'émotion
qu'on a vu c'est d'amener cadelade
manquer chez fassa pierce à l'abandon
alors c'est peut-être un peu ça qui
restera pour filmer pour lui on le voit
qu'il maîtrise très bien ses dossiers
les propositions du pq on l'arrête et au
fait est-ce qu'on va vraiment les
écouter parce que des fois ça peut être
complexe où ça va dans le détail ça
reste à voir on nous promet des annonces
domaines par exemple sur la question de
l'immigration puis monsieur plamondon ça
vient permanent voulais pas en parler ce
soir c'est trop compliqué de même genre
par l'ue pour s'endetter alors c'est un
peu ça c'est réponse dans puis cette
émotion là qu'on voit un peu moins bien
par contre plusieurs personnes vont
certainement apprendre à le connaître
puis peut-être volts et intérêts c'est
écouter la suite des chances fait basse
terre il parla qui passaient à piller
enfin mon nom je pense que la stratégie
du parti québécois et de son chef depuis
le début de la campagne électorale c'est
de parler ou 30 % des gens qui se dit
souveraine et esprit il comme michel
disait personnes pensent vraiment que
gabriel nadeau dubois sera le premier
ministre à l'issue de ces élections
personne ne pense que paul st pierre
plamondon sera le premier ministre n'ont
plus alors que lui reste-t-il lui reste
à s'assumer dans ses convictions
souverainistes de défense de la langue
française et parler aux gens qui sont
sur la même longueur d'onde que lui et
pour espérer en amasser le plus possible
pour faire élire le plus possible des
lecteurs de députés pardon et ce soir
j'avais l'impression qu'il parlait
beaucoup à ces gens là pour essayer de
leur expliquer que le véritable
indépendantistes c'est le parti
québécois et que même si québec
solidaire se dit souverainiste
indépendantiste
ils n'ont pas la foi ou la flamme comme
le parti québécois peut la voir donc
l'idée c'est d'attirer d'attirer ces
gens là vers le particulier en terminant
éric duhaime chef conservateur est ce
qu'il a réussi à se présenter ce soir
comme chef dont le parti est plus que
canal de mécontentement d'une partie de
la population
sébastien il a beaucoup parlé porter sur
la façon dont monsieur duhaime et son
parti se sont comportés face aux mesures
sanitaires donc je pense que c'est il
traîne c'est encore pire le défi d'éric
duhaime c'est de se faire connaître
autrement que pour ça pour essayer
d'élargir sa tante et ce soir il n'a pas
nécessairement réussi à avoir cette
opportunité je pense d'expliquer un peu
plus au programme d'expliquer sa vision
quoique
sur certains points les hydrocarbures
par exemple gnl québec il a fait passer
son point qu'il voulait développer ce
genre de
d'infrastructures en passant il dit
qu'on aurait pu aider les allemands avec
le projet de gnl québec pas tout à fait
vrai parce que le projet de gnl québec
aurait été en fonction seulement en 2006
et pas en 2022 dont j'ai des fois
quelques raccourcis dans les
explications de monsieur gilles
geneviève et michel
alesi j'aime bien c'est le parti de la
colère pour le vu encore ce soir donc
est ce que le parti conservateur du
québec va toujours avec ce parti de la
colère c'est ça qu'on la question que
les gens vont se poser il ya parlait
beaucoup de la crise sanitaire à la
faille à parler d'autre chose mais on
reste un peu sur notre faim se fait
talonner ou est-ce que vous allez coupé
dit que du gras gay où il devra dans
l'appareil public puis bon on n'avait
pas vraiment de réponse donc c'est un
conte est la proposition je vois ce
qu'ils vont pouvoir élargir la crise
appuyé en demeure ont campé dans cette
folle r oui je sais vous avez le mot de
la fin
c'était une occasion largement respect
pour le su tuer une avait la chance de
montrer qu'ils étaient justement autre
chose que le porte parole de la grogne à
cause de la crise centene ya passé un
beaucoup beaucoup de temps sur la crise
sanitaire et n'a pas eu beaucoup pour
enlever du reste de son programme
bondiront dépeindre est parti on a des
priorités ailleurs et ça c'est quelque
chose qui va bien qu'ils vont revenir à
toute la campagne électorale et vous
autres choses que juste la colère qui a
été
révélée par la famille